What is that?
This is the car.
What year is that?
This is the year that I did 23.
I'll play that year.
Yeah, that was the year.
The year of the leg.
Big earphones.
This has got big end of watch mics to it.
Dude.
The handy cam.
Oh yeah, it's sick. The phone comes up.
Oh, he doesn't know our channel. Go on YouTube.
Look up First 5 Rugby.
I won't, but I'll say that I will.
I've seen big Cloverfield bottles.
Oh, I've seen one of those too.
You haven't seen them?
No, I haven't.
Well, I hated that movie.
False advertising.
Not a single clover in the entire film.
If someone would nominally
Irish heritage, I'm offended.
The monster's name was Clover.
You know, I didn't really get that.
I didn't think it came across clearly.
Da-da.
Get on the floor.
Oh.